[Musique]
dans l'univers des g
oui s'amuser et tout ce qui compte
mais pour kamba tout cela est sur le
point de changer épouse et moi tous
c'est une urgence les paul est mort
finir ma chasse et une fois pour toutes
on verra qui vivent sous l'ihs le démon
blond
martial tu peux compter sur moi chloé
pas aux producteurs de spider man et
iron man quand laventure frappe à votre
porte soyez prêts à braver l'inconnu et
apprendre votre envol celui qui a causé
la perte de monde
joe degrés cet après midi c'était tout à
damas
n'écoutez pas ce que vous dit martial
surtout ce sont parfois les plus petits
héros qui écrit les plus grandes
histoires
[Musique]
c'est parti les aventures de gamba